the pH of the soft drink is 3.37
after the addition of the potassium
sorbate which species the sorbic acid or
the sorbate ion has a higher
concentration in the soft drink justify
your answer so this is related to the
question we've been doing because the
sorbate ion this is this is what happens
when you put potassium sorbate and it
disassociates in a solution so the
concentration of the sorbate ion is the
same thing as the concentration one way
to think about it saying is is is going
to be the same as the concentration of
your potassium sorbate and so if we're
thinking about if we're thinking about
titrating potassium sorbate which we've
been doing in the last several parts of
the problem at what point do you have an
equal concentration of potassium sorbate
and and sorbic acid well you have equal
concentrations at the half equivalence
point we mark that out when we we
figured it out in the last few parts of
this problem and the half equivalence
point happened at a pH of four point we
actually figured it out before four
point seven seven so we could say we
could say half equivalence point half
half equivalence quillin's point of
titration of potassium sorbate
potassium sorbate with hydrochloric acid
happens happens at a pH of let me write
that pH of four point seven seven and
that's the point at which you have equal
concentrations of so we can put this in
parentheses can be viewed as point where
we have
equal concentrations concentrations of
of c6h 7:02 - and the sorbic acid h c 6h
702 pH of 3.77
pH of 3.37 is lower and will thus or we
could say will happen beyond half
equivalence point beyond half e
equivalence gravel its point so
concentration of the sorbic acid is
higher so concentration asian of sorbic
acid h c 6h 702 is higher when you're
starting off if you're doing a titration
your your concentration of potassium
sorbate it'll be higher then you keep
titrating it keeps reacting with the
hydrochloric acid you get to the half
equivalence point where these two things
are going to have equally concentrations
and you if you keep titrating it well
then you're gonna become more acidic and
you're going to have a higher
concentration of the sorbic acid and so
one way to think about actually
underlying that whole part so
concentration of sorbic acid is higher
that's the main thing that they're
they're asking for but the way to think
about this soft drink is something it
might have not obviously people aren't
sitting there and titrating every soft
drink but you could kind of view this
soft drink as well and got to that point
after a theoretical titration that got
us past the high past the past the half
equivalence point and so therefore most
of
of our the things that we care about as
in the form as in this acid form versus
the conjugate base most of the the
sorbic acid isn't it is in its acid form
or I guess you could say the other way
most of the sorbate has become the
conjugate acid